tous les êtres humains naissent libres
et égaux en dignité et en droits c'est
par ces quelques mots que commence
l'article 1 de la déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme
signant 48 par 52 pays depuis la
démocratie a gagné de nouveau bastion et
plusieurs nations se sont ralliés à ce
texte fondateur
mais les droits de l'homme sont encore
régulièrement bafoués retour sur ces 50
ans avec florent muller et roland barry
celle plus jamais ça effrayés par les
atrocités de la seconde guerre mondiale
la nouvelle assemblée des nations unies
élabore en 1948 une déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme signée
le 10 décembre au palais de chaillot
ce document composé de 30 articles a
pour but d'instaurer la paix et la
justice dans le monde
cinquante ans plus tard en 98 certains
des articles de cette déclaration sont
toujours violés
article 3 tout individu a droit à la vie
à la liberté et à la sûreté de sa
personne depuis 92 la terreur règne en
algérie
on estime à 60 mille le nombre de morts
depuis le début de la guerre civile
ces six derniers jours 60 personnes ont
été massacrées article 9 nul ne peut
être arbitrairement arrêté détenu ou
exilé juillet 98 birmanie le prix nobel
de la paix aung san suu kyi et retenu
pendant une semaine dans sa voiture par
les autorités de son pays en liberté
surveillée elle ne pourra se rendre à
paris mais a tenu à envoyer ce message
et firmine richard
[Musique]
un campus de skema article 14 devant la
persécution toute personne a le droit de
chercher asile afrique dans la région
des grands lacs les réfugiés hutus ont
été victimes de nombreux massacres lors
de la prise du pouvoir par laurent
désiré kabila
article 25 toute personne a droit à un
niveau de vie suffisant pour assurer sa
santé
1,3 milliard de personnes vivent
aujourd'hui avec moins d'un dollar par
jour
ici au soudan 2 5 millions d'habitants
risquent de mourir de faim naturellement
beaucoup des valeurs incorporé dans la
déclaration universelle sont encore des
utopies des rêves mais beaucoup aussi se
sont réalisés dans les fêtes les
partisans des droits de l'homme ont
connu quelques succès en 50 ans
l'arrestation du général pinochet qui
sera peut être jugé en espagne et la
condamnation des criminels de guerre de
l'ex yougoslavie sans oublier la
décolonisation et la construction de
l'europe
lentement la déclaration prend des
allures de loi internationale
[Musique]